we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p here's a voicemail that came in
take a listen to this hi mr. Parkman
this is david from Riverside I have an
idea since you were recently talking
about changing the show format on
Fridays how about more hey tree at nail
that's honestly my favorite my favorite
part of the show that'd be the greatest
thing I think to like an hour-long
episode of all the hatred mail you
haven't shown us to be fantastic you
guys do a great job see you soon here's
what people don't get the whole point of
patriot mail is it's a little morsel so
that people want more of it but if we
give everybody more of it then it
becomes boring and people don't like it
anymore so we have to deliberately we
regularly get asked for more hey treat
male by not doing more hatred mail we
keep people interested in hatred mail if
you do a gag for an hour right if the
friday show becomes patriot mail for an
hour and by the way we would have an
hour don't don't believe that we would
not have enough material then hatred
mail is no longer interesting or unique
well luckily we do live calls which
sometimes get adversarial and even
sometimes the classic interviews are
adversarial yeah a hatreds do appear in
the friday show just not in the same
format not with their voicemails
transcribed by a professional movie
voice-over artist it's a little
different yeah different type of thing
on the bonus show today protesters have
raised more than two hundred thousand
dollars to buy congress's browsing
histories chase has had very interesting
results with their new advertising
strategy on the internet and russia is
involved not only in trying to influence
American elections but also the upcoming
French election and other European
elections all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show there is one way
to get access to the bonus show and it's
by signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership if you want a discount have a
discount by using coupon code I voted 17
all one word all lowercase